I have an interesting clip to pay play
for you from Eric Weinstein's podcast
the portal which I actually listen to
it's quite an interesting podcast where
my name came up in a discussion with Sam
Harris now I want to be really clear
especially because Eric and Sam might
see this YouTube clip the YouTube clip
title is sort of a joke my YouTube
titles are often sort of jokes we play
around satirically with the ways that
it's become sort of in vogue to title
YouTube clips this person was destroyed
that person was attacked whatever it's
just a joke so please that the YouTube
titles are meant to be interesting but
the important thing is the discussion it
was reported to me over the weekend that
Eric Weinstein attacked me and that sam
harris defended me on eric's podcast now
this was actually an interesting
discussion about tactics versus
substance I think I'm being accurate
when I say that Eric Weinstein and Sam
Harris agree with much of the substance
of the left's positions but seriously
question many of its tactics and I've
spoken with Sam Harris about this when
he was on the program so a few names
came up during this discussion sam
cedars name came up and others i don't
remember who else and when my name comes
up sam harris says David Pakman I have
seen act in good faith and Eric
Weinstein says well not always let's
take a listen to a couple of minutes
from Eric's show yeah well that's
ridicule but you're ridiculing something
that you strawman did didn't understand
right because the person actually was
making sense and so what I see is that
the left and in particular the Sam cedar
crowd has a doing that with abandon what
it's willing to do two separate things
sama is quite Welling like there's this
whole thing but when you talk to Sam
cedar will you debate Sam cedar and my
feeling is I would debate part of Sam
cedar the part that just is focused on
the ideas but the part that is kind of
like nasty and ridic in ridiculing and
doing the Alinsky thing I don't know
what to do with it I'm not interested
I've spoken to Sam cedar and the phone
is perfectly reasonable made sense to me
we disagreed on on positions but well
the the line that gets crossed for me
always with these guys and again it's a
is
disproportionately on the left is the
the line of conscious dishonesty missus
serious your brother's aphorism bad
faith changes every that fate changes
everything and these guys are in bad
faith they know they're lying about in
my case my views my actual beliefs and
not all of them that there's just too
much information or Pakman no David
Pakman fine I just did his podcast yeah
I know but David Pakman said some pretty
non charitable things in some parts that
seem kind of ridiculing and I think you
me other people though I haven't
whatever I haven't I have never seen him
misrepresent my views and I think that
made again I don't know I'm I just did
his podcast once but he seems like the
he seems like somebody who if I said
listen you got me wrong here that would
matter and he would he would make an
effort to abduct me and that got me
right which is the problem that we have
increasingly is that the tactics that
are being used in what are called
progressive circles have been confused
with the content so that is the
objection to the vehicle which might be
saw Lansky's rules for radicals with a
totally unethical program for smearing
people dishonestly being non charitable
I actually don't think is objectively a
problem I start from a position of
charity and I think we all should when
we analyze or critique something but if
we find a reason why someone maybe
doesn't deserve our fullest charity we
can retract that charity in good faith
that can still be a good faith action we
don't have to endlessly steal man every
false notion that we hear come out of
anybody's mouth once we have a better
systemic or holistic assessment of their
character and whether they act in good
faith or bad faith but that's not really
the issue here now sam harris asks
whether i said things ridiculing him and
of course the answer is no what eric
weinstein is referring to is a clip
where i talked generally about the
intellectual dark web and I said you
know
it is not as intellectual as they may
want you to think and I got dozens of
emails from people saying David are you
saying Sam Harris isn't an intellectual
each time I would answer calmly and
clearly I'm not saying that Sam Harris
isn't an intellectual what I am saying
is that less there is less
intellectualism in the intellectual dark
web
then they as a loosely organized group
might want you to think and that doesn't
just refer to the stars of the IDW but
it also refers to a lot of the followers
as well now here's an example just to be
thorough of when someone would ask me
very concerned David were you talking
about Sam Harris not being an
intellectual here's just one example of
that coming up in me responding hey
David I just listened to your take on
the pseudo intellectualism and I agree
with most those folks that were named in
that article but Sam Harris really I
understand no he's a pseudo intellectual
is it because he offends numerous people
and he brings up the ideas of
Christianity and Islam are completely
foolish and stupid that's the only thing
I could think of other than that I'm I'm
lost help me out David oh don't do it so
listen I mentioned Sam Harris once in
yesterday's story merely in that he was
mentioned in a New York Times article
called the intellectual dark web web by
Barry Weiss I mentioned Sam Harris's
name and a number of other names only
insofar as I was telling you about the
article that sort of got me thinking
about the story I did yesterday
I never said yesterday that Sam Harris
is not an intellectual I've read a lot
of sam Harris's work I have some
political disagreements with Sam Harris
I think that his book the moral
landscape is endlessly fascinating I've
never really taken a position on whether
Sam Harris is or isn't an intellectual I
I think I believe that he is and that's
okay to say that and still say that I
disagree with some of the stuff that he
said my commentary yesterday was not
about saying sam Harris is not on
actual and if that's mostly what you
focused on you really miss the point of
my entire commentary okay so no I never
said Sam Harris isn't an intellectual I
mentioned his name yesterday in passing
as one of many five six seven different
people that were mentioned by Barry
Weiss I think Steven Pinker was
mentioned I'm not saying steven pinker
is not an intellectual the commentary
was about the environment in which
pseudo intellectual ism and faux
intellectualism is sort of welcomed and
embraced by people rather than about
saying who is or isn't on the list of
intellectuals now it is true that for
example Dave Rubin is not an
intellectual you can agree or disagree
with the the sort of libertarian
small-government talking points that
Dave Rubin has adopted over the last
couple of years but Dave Rubin is not an
intellectual and I think that that is a
perfectly reasonable thing to say it's
not an attack on anybody it's just I
don't even think Dave Rubin would say
although I don't know that he is an
intellectual what Eric is referring to
and I've spoken to Eric personally about
this is that my comments at the time
were probably general enough that
somebody who doesn't know me and Eric
didn't know me at the time and I didn't
know Eric at the time someone could
interpret what I was saying to mean that
there are no intellectuals in the
intellectual dark web that is of course
now very clearly not what I meant but
much of the story was actually about the
pseudo intellectual ism in the
audience's of the IDW movement to the
extent that those exists not about the
members themselves this is a totally
different conversation now at the same
time this is a critique I've made about
people who read you know Bill O'Reilly
pop history books and read nothing else
and think they are now informed
historians because they read Bill
O'Reilly take on Abraham Lincoln or
whatever it is a different story and it
is a story about the ways in which the
messages from doesn't matter who it is
and I'm not equate exam Harris to Bill
O'Reilly believe me it is a story about
the followers which is a very
interesting one actually that I think
deserves a lot of examinations so the
fair critique of me based on what Eric
is saying is David Pakman wasn't clearer
precise enough when I made my initial
commentary about the intellectual dark
web
commentaries by the way at this point
are roughly two years old I looked for
my IDW critiques that Eric was referring
to and I found a clip from May of 2018
which maybe is the one maybe they're
even older I don't know so I know what
Eric is referring to Eric and I have had
nice conversations we've been talking
about maybe getting him on the David
Pakman show me being on his show if I'm
in LA at some point I have proposed some
dates to Eric for being on with me I
have not heard back but it's still
something I'm interested in I think most
of my audience knows that even if you
disagree with me on my conclusions I am
a good faith actor who simply calls
things like I see them and I am not
deliberately dishonest so I I'm fine
with this discussion that took place and
I think everybody was reasonably
respectful although I simply disagree
with the characterization of what Eric
said about my previous comments